Raid on Bungeling Bay.
On a tiny, remote planet, the evil Bungeling Empire is creating an awesome war machine.
Civilization as we know it seems doomed.
One faint hope remains.
NOSTALGIA And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Joe. I'm Sam.
And I'm Sean.
NOSTALGIA And today, at approximately one second ago, we learned that Raid on Bungeling Bay and Lode Runner take place in a shared universe where, as one helicopter is trying to destroy a galactic empire, another lone man is robbing their facilities.
NOSTALGIA I like to think of it in the way that Lode Runner failed.
You know, this is the universe where he failed.
NOSTALGIA And they kept all the gold and they invested it in military technology.
No, no, you're wrong.
This is a game that spans millennia.
There's been a fight between the Bungelings and the humans for so long that they went from caves and gold to helicopters and war machines.
NOSTALGIA No, no, no. You're both wrong.
This is a game where these two things are happening exactly simultaneously.
While you're in the helicopter shooting at bases, the other guy's in one of those bases collecting that gold and has got to get out in time.
NOSTALGIA Stay tuned next time for the fan fiction edition.
NOSTALGIA You're all wrong because these two games are definitely not related and this is a stretch by Broderbund, the publisher of the games, to try to link them up on their own because these games were definitely created by two totally different people.
Oh, and Santa's not real, huh?
NOSTALGIA Yeah, Doug Smith. Whoa.
Whoa. It could be little children.
We got some new listeners listening to this. NOSTALGIA
Sam's fine. Sam's Jewish, so he could care less if people found out the truth about Santa.
NOSTALGIA And by truth, I mean false truth.
I was saying like you don't believe.
NOSTALGIA I was saying it like you don't believe.
NOSTALGIA Yeah, don't tell me Santa's a false flag.
NOSTALGIA Alright, Raid on Bungeling Bay, we have to talk about that this game was developed by William Wright.
NOSTALGIA Who is William Wright, Sean?
NOSTALGIA Will Wright is the developer of SimCity.
NOSTALGIA And this game was pretty much what made him make SimCity.
NOSTALGIA Okay, yes, that is true.
I thought you could just keep listing off some cool things he's done like The Sims.
NOSTALGIA Oh, well, yeah, but that's less important.
NOSTALGIA SimCity, The Sims, and most importantly, Spore.
NOSTALGIA Wait, was that?
NOSTALGIA No, that wasn't him.
NOSTALGIA Yeah, yeah, William Wright was
I thought that was Peter Molyneux for some reason.
NOSTALGIA The Tiger?
NOSTALGIA The Connectimals game.
NOSTALGIA I don't think he did
No, Connectimals is a totally different thing, but I just want to hold him responsible
for anything that didn't pan out on the Xbox 360.
Like, it was his fault.
NOSTALGIA He also had that game where you click on cubes.
NOSTALGIA We're still talking about Peter Molyneux?
NOSTALGIA Yeah. NOSTALGIA It was a game where you click on cubes and like eventually somebody was gonna click the
last cube. NOSTALGIA
I'm not joking. NOSTALGIA
Look all this up. It's crazy.
NOSTALGIA He gets, he's a little bit too big for his britches.
NOSTALGIA I admire his, his, uh, his aspirations.
You could say William Wright is almost the opposite though, uh, up until Spore.
Like, he just kept envisioning bigger and bigger things each time and they were succeeding.
Like, first it was...
NOSTALGIA Well, he kept getting small.
Well, okay. No, you're right.
In the beginning he kept getting bigger.
NOSTALGIA But it is a smaller scope.
NOSTALGIA Smaller scope, but it's more personal.
NOSTALGIA Yeah, I think it's more personal.
NOSTALGIA It's a deeper dive.
NOSTALGIA Yeah, but that's not what I meant.
I think it's, but I think it's also just actually, it's more expansive than, than SimCity.
It's just a house. NOSTALGIA
Yeah, okay. Sure. NOSTALGIA
Yeah, but there's emotions and there's...
But you control everything about it and the person inside of you.
NOSTALGIA You can go to a job.
NOSTALGIA We had it on Super NES.
Then there was SimAnt.
Yes. Which was...
SimCopter can't forget the Sims
large expansion packs for the original Sims
there's a lot of expansions
for the original Sims too
and also we should start talking about
Raid on Bungeling Bits
I think it's important that we talk about William Wright though
because I think we can't
understate his importance
Doug Smith, cool guy, developed Lode Runner
I thought that was awesome William Wright is one of the
he's one of the original pioneers
of video games
so this game
Raid on Bungeling Bay was released on the
Commodore 64 first
in 1984 and then came
to the NES in September of 87
we're still on that long train of September
I think we said something like 17 games
which is weird because
17 games came out during the
entire NES launch
and now it's like that's just September
Hudson Soft
again for the NES version
which makes sense because Broderbund again
for publisher for the North American version
guys let's talk about the gameplay
for Raid on Bungeling Bay
before we go any further
because if we try to talk about this game
without telling the audience what they're doing
I think like this one really surprised me
so who wants to take it?
I think I'll go ahead
alright Sean so in this game
you play as
the single
lone
like agitator
in a war
you're the military yeah you are
you are the military
just like you
in several other games
you're the only person
fighting for your side
but you
you're a guy
who's based on
a World War 2 era
aircraft carrier
and you go
and try to bomb factories
before they build
the war machine
that will destroy Earth
but in the meantime
you have to deal with
a slowly but surely
evolving
defense force
that
if you're not quick
will create a battleship
to sink your only hope
of like just surviving
yeah and
and on top of that too
I can't overstate the whole like
real-time element
of this game which is like
the coolest part of it
is that time actually does matter
because it's not about like
okay now that you've defeated the first factory
the game gets harder
it's actually about time
and that the factories
will continue to
churn out more enemies
they'll churn out
like tougher things
they'll become stronger
and it's interesting
how time plays
in this game and there are other factors
that like surprise me too
like there are little radar satellites
that if you're near one
it'll alert it'll draw more enemies
to you because it's alerting
the enemies as to where you are
that's in the manual
whether
whether or not
like there are any
like interconnected systems
that are causing these things
to happen just the scope
of the game the fact that
it's a
360 degree
wrapping map
that's pretty huge
combined with
at least like
the illusion
that everything
is sort of working together
like it
it really creates
at least the effect
of a simulation yeah it's all happening
in real time there's no loading screens
there's no cutscenes
there's no like when this thing happens
like things will change
things just change
as they're like
scripted to do
yeah through time
so you really do
have to kind of like
you know
rush to find these locations
of the factories fast
because if you're not fast enough
in bombing them
they're gonna be able to
rebuild themselves
too and rebuild
their army
so this way
you won't be able to continue
to take them down and I like even
one thing that's cool
about this game is that
other than the helicopter
which you control
there is a carrier
that you can continue
to go back to get some health
and replenish
your bombs but the interesting
thing is that even that carrier
is susceptible
to enemy attack
and can be destroyed
yeah and if that carrier
is destroyed that's kind of like
you know
now you're now this is what
you have yeah you got those bombs
and if you can't do it
then you're done because you need
the carrier to reload
right uh so let's talk
a little bit about just the
real-time element
of things obviously that
that was the
gameplay mechanic but how much
did you guys feel it personally
I'd like to go around the room
actually and just share experiences
so Joe
how much
did like you know
the factories building against you
and like the army
getting larger
and larger feel
in your gameplay
experience at first
almost not at all
actually for a while I just thought the game
was getting more difficult
I didn't read the manual
at first I wasn't
I was kind of figuring out my goal
as I went I was actually
wasn't clear that I was supposed
to be bombing
the factories because the game
totally just drops
you right in it doesn't explain
a thing right but after a while
I did start to realize
that you know I noticed these satellites
they weren't attacking me
but I could destroy them
so radar dish
sorry apologies everyone
so they I started to
I looked into the manual
about that and was like
whoa these are actually affecting things
and then I started to realize
like the amount of enemies
that are coming at me and eventually
something what is another
battleship attacked my
aircraft carrier
and that's where
I was like wow this game
is like really attacking me
now and then I kind of
started to piece it together
but it took me a little while
to figure it out sure
Sean um
yeah it really
comes at you
pretty quickly
after you've bombed
a couple factories and it does feel
like a natural
uh like build up
like I actually
sort of it is pretty immersive
this game
uh when it comes to
uh
watching
things evolve on the ground
um I was
I really liked
the fact that like
in the midpoint
like mid
factory
destroyer
um section
how many factories
are there do we remember
I think it was oh six
or seven
but yeah no you're probably
right um well anyway
you can actually
like see on some
of the islands or I guess
continents whatever you want
to call them
uh full like
airstrips or airfields
and you could
see the um
the fighter planes
or the bombers either like
landing or about to
take off and I just
really wanted to get them
before they
took off um
it did feel
like you were trying to
slow
an almost
uh unstoppable
force yeah
uh Sam anything
dead um
not really I kind of
just like I
this is one where I looked
at the manual after I started
playing it and I was
just kind of flying around
a little bit not really sure
what was going
on just idly
waiting for the
army to come to you
yeah uh
and you know they did
after I looked at the
manual and realized it had
to be destroying factories
uh and
yeah I don't really
have anything to add one thing you
learned pretty fast
too is that like taking down a
factory isn't as simple as just
dropping one
bomb yeah we're talking about
this like they take a lot
right yeah that that I thought
was a little bit annoying personally
but um
as far as like
the systems of
this goes I thought it
was it was interesting
once I got into it
and you know I was like
once I got an alert
that was kind of fun
yeah I think
like one thing that's really
interesting is if you guys
remember Miyamoto talking about
with Legend of Zelda how
that idea that it would
just be like one world
that's just kind of like
things are just going on
right and we know that that's
not true because things just animate
on when you get to the next
screen but it
does kind of feel like that
this game takes
that a step further while
obviously reducing
the scale just focusing on
one particular mission but I
kind of appreciate
this game a lot
yeah the way
that it like the way that it
set like a very
clear objective assuming you've
read the manual I think they could
have done a little more legwork on
like in the title
screen or something to like also
just the paragraph yeah exactly
but just like
they do enough
in just that one the clearness
of the one mission
and just like
the fact that
the goal always
remains the same of how to
defeat factories but they definitely
like scale up
in difficulty as time goes by
not just because they're also
building themselves
but that you
you know it takes more
bombs and
there's only a certain amount
of bombs you can carry
so by factory
number three you must stop
at the carrier to pick up
a second load of bombs
because you won't have
enough in a single drop
to destroy
the factory and so
that like added to the
pressure too and you have
to you know it's easy to
find your first
factory I feel like because you
can just kind of go off in any
direction but in the later
ones you kind of have to think about
where have I been
where do I need to go like what
have I seen mental map
line marks
and I also think
one thing that
this game does well is
like switching between modes
like offense
and defense like yeah
you'll be off on a search
and then suddenly
you'll get that alert
and now you
have to completely change your
perspective and say like
okay I have to remember where I
was and just get there as
fast as possible I think this game
had a lot of tense moments
in there I tried doing
both at some points where
you know usually
I just go as slow as I can
over the factories to make sure I
hit it but there were some points
where you know the planes are
coming at me and I'm saying
all right I'm gonna shoot the
planes and then
yeah precision drop
to fly directly
over the factory while I'm chasing
planes and drop
a bomb and you
know those moments felt really cool
yeah I definitely felt like the
fighter jets put on
the most amount of pressure like
the tanks were kind of like easy
yeah the boats
don't really bother you yeah
boats are just like kind of out
for a nice boat
ride they might just be fishing
for all we know yeah but they're
fishing as the enemy yes yeah
the enemy is
fishing and we can't let them
have food those are innocent fish
yeah switching
gears a little bit
uh and correct me
if I'm wrong but like just going back
down to a more
like micro level of
this game the
controls um the
way that you control the
helicopter is more
of like a tank
um is this the
first time that we've had like
tank controls in
an NES game no I mean I
guess it depends on how you look
at it like we've had we've had
similar things in
uh what was it
ikari warriors had
the tank where
yeah but that was a little bit
different I think
because what you're getting at is like
if you're facing facing any direction
north is forward
yeah if you're facing yeah exactly
if you're facing north then east is
you know to your
right but if you're facing south like
maybe I'm describing
this in a really weird way if you're
facing up on the
screen you hit right
to go to the right but if you're facing
down you hit right
to go to the
helicopter's right so
it's like asteroids
control oh gotcha
okay yeah so no in
that case I don't think we've really had a
game like that yeah
yeah and it it caught
me off guard a little bit but once I
realized what was going on it was you
know it was great I thought the controls
worked really well and there's also like
several levels of
acceleration too yeah
you know if you're
going the manual
says like it
increased oh sorry
go ahead in the manual I think it
says it increases in
30 percent increments
or something all the way up to 100 and
to the point where you're going to
standstill too which helps when you're
over the factory yeah because you
definitely want to be hovering over
those factories and
also the reverse you
have to hold down I
think yeah you can't
just go full reverse
which I think is also convenient because if
you're trying to break and then all
of a sudden you're flying backwards you
know and to be
honest I initially
as soon as I started
using the controls I was a little aggravated
by them but like you
said once I got the
hang of it I think that's the only way
this game works so
well that's the only reason this game feels
so good to control is
like you the way you
can kind of swing around with these
controls and and
after acceleration yeah you don't have
to hold it down to go
forward like you can
you set your
acceleration to like
one thing yeah I'll
be like orbiting
around a tank or
something like going
just out of reach and
then coming back and
swooping in it's it's
fun to fly the helicopter expressive
maneuvering I think
yeah and what do we
think about the choice for a
helicopter as opposed
to like a fighter jet
like take it or leave
it interesting I like
the idea yeah I think
it's definitely different like it's not take it
or leave it because you have you have the
option to hover like
you were saying and you have I think this
game would be way too
but I mean I know
there is a lot of
frustration in this game
that we haven't really touched upon too much
but this would this
game would be way too frustrating if you had
to go at a at a
fighter pilot speed at
all times it's like
the precision that you
need in this game can
only be done with like
a hovercraft or a
helicopter yeah I think
it works really well so Sean you talked
about some of the frustrations would you
like to kind of crack
open that one and talk
a little bit about like what you didn't find
satisfying um well I
think the first I think
the most glaring one is
that the sound in this
game is atrocious um what
about that it's music it
sounds okay the music track
is the least uh the least
offensive really I thought
the music track was it's
two notes yeah I know but
it's just like very low
bass tones that you can
sort of tune out after a
while whereas if you are
in a in a fight it it
sounds like a nine inch
nails breakdown where he
just like smashes the
the synthesizer um it it
sounds like the sound chip
can't handle it I guess
that's true it sounds a little like it's peaking
yeah yeah yeah the fighter
jets especially I think
are just kind of they're a
lot yeah exactly but
sometimes that's good though because it's kind
of like this intimidating
sound it is an intimidating
sound I think one thing
that frustrated me about
this game and and maybe
it was like part of the
game's themes you know
was like there's a there's
like a fatalism to this
game where it's like I
don't know about you guys
but there came a point
where I I was just always
as soon as I was like
well it was a good
attempt but now the army
has bested me you know
like yeah there came a
point where it's just like too much like too
much time has passed you
really had to like memorize where all the
factories were or else you
know you're just not going to get to them fast enough
and now you're kind of
like overwhelmed by the
army that they've built
and the fortresses they've
created it really reminds
you that you're one guy
against your planet's army
yeah I think that one
thing that really
illustrates it that was
definitely intentional is
you don't just blow up
like in a lot of these a
lot of games we've played
like you have a good few
seconds to just accept
what's happened and
spiral out of control
you you are encouraged to
try and like aim your
crash at the factory
right like just to
suicide into it because
all hope is lost yeah I
think um one one thing
while I was um while I
was playing like my first
round of it was just
kind of thinking like okay not not that bad but
I just gotta do it a little faster and like the fact
that that became the motto each time I tried
over again I think there
was there was a point
where I kind of wondered
like okay how much of
this game is is going to
be reduced to like
memorization of locations
and how much of it is
going to be chalked up
to like can I fight the
army or not because I
think there is just a
point where you become
overwhelmed yeah by it
and I don't know if there's a if there's ever
a moment where plateaus
like I don't know where
it's like max capacity
for the other and I'm
not saying the game's impossible I'm saying
that I just I think my
biggest complaint is that
in a game where it's like living and
breathing world where
things are happening it
is kind of weird that
it encourages like a
memorization yeah and
I almost wish that like
this game like the map
changed each time
updates you know like
like so this way yeah
and just this way it was
like you couldn't you
never got a chance to
get comfortable you know
like after a few
playthroughs I knew the
first three I was gonna
hit because they were near each other you know
I'd only have to go to
the factory back to the
carrier it doesn't even
need to be doesn't even
need to be like some
weird algorithm that
creates new continents
you just move the
continents right no
exactly and I think
like yeah there would
probably be like some
some that just offer
like terrible balance but
I mean we play the
pandemic board game and
that happens to us sometimes too with the
luck of the cards you
know so it's like okay just you had a bad run
reset or oh this was an
easier time but that's
because in this timeline
the empire sucked the
only thing that would kind of hurt is if I if if I'm
competing against you for
a better score than you
then it's hard to it's
hard to be true the game does have a score
part two which I just
thought was strange but
I did like how it does
reward like the quickness
again like you do get a
bonus if you defeat the
things faster than you should and I don't know
how it calculates that
but I appreciated that
and I think like yeah I
think like at the end of
the day I was kind of
like I could care less about my score there's a
mission here like that's
really what I care about
gotta save the world
yeah save which world
I'm not sure yeah but you gotta save
the guy who's collecting the gold and inside
yeah you're just trying
to stall so we can get
all the gold you're
just a distraction yeah
that's the lore now does anybody else have
any straight thoughts I wanted to talk about
two-player okay now I
didn't I didn't play with
anyone but I just wanted to see what two-player
was all about so I I
gave it a try just to
see what you're controlling you're
controlling what player
one is controlling the helicopter player two is
controlling like the turrets and stuff yeah I
like that asymmetric
multiplayer you don't
see too much of that
usually it's just like
take turns or sort of
like a messy co-op it
was the best it was the
best solve here for sure
because if you think
about it if you had a
second helicopter how
would you control the screen right like it
would have to be like a
sonic and tails situation
where the secondary
helicopter is just there
yeah and we'll just
complete yeah whatever
happens to screw it like
we care about player
number one yeah yeah and
I obviously since I was
just myself with two
controllers I only played
for like a second I'm
not sure if you if you
control anything other than the turrets or if
you could ever control
like a like a fighter
plane or anything like that but as far as I
know you're just controlling like the
turrets I'm fairly
certain that you only
ever control the helicopter but I'm
no I mean the player
two yeah player two
other enemies I don't
think you control the other enemies I'm
fairly certain you only
ever control the turret
part of the helicopter but I think it's like a
cool no no no you're
controlling the enemy you're controlling the
enemy like the
turrets on the ground player one oh yeah
yeah yeah okay I
completely miss I mean
obviously I didn't play two player but I
completely misunderstood what they were talking
about yeah okay can you
attack the like the bad
guys also well I don't
think it would have to be
all on the same screen
so this is okay we're all
just sort of like shooting in the dark
yeah but I do I like it
though because we don't
totally know what's
happening but I I'm kind
of more yeah we got to
play this I really do want to play it I think I like
that less than what I
read into I read into the
idea that like you were
controlled like somebody
was controlling the firing
aspect of the helicopter
and the other person was controlling the maneuvering
of the helicopter and I
kind of like that more
as I don't know I find I
find it more interesting
that you are trying to
fight the play player yeah
I think that's cool
because it's it's
different yeah and from
what I gathered from my
quick my quick test of this
is that which whenever
you're flying whatever
turret is on the screen
you're the player two is
just controlling that turret for me that that
that was something that I
was like kind of sad I
missed out on but now I'm
just kind of like and all
he did was control the
turrets like whatever I
don't know really I feel like that would that would
change unique yeah we've
played yet like yeah I
just now I really want to
feel like that the play you
know like when player one
has the ability to just
kind of like control where
they are in the environment
and you're just kind of
like I like the idea more
of the co-op nature of it
than just you're the
turrets I don't know
something something about
that just seems I like
the asymmetric style of
it but to each their own
I guess okay yeah all
right cool if we don't
have anything else straight thoughts any
others no okay cool
we'll go into some great
developer quotes from the
man himself William Wright
which one would you like
first publishing or
gameplay I'll take
gameplay for 400 Alex
all right this is William
Wright on gameplay I
came up with the idea of
this big scrolling window
and I'd always loved
helicopters so I just
basically designed the
end game around the technology around what
you could do on the
Commodore that you could
not do on the Apple
while I was making it I
had to build other programs to help me build
that program I had to
build a program that
would realign character
sets another one would
let you scroll around the
world and place these
little tiles to build
these islands and roads
and such I had more fun
with that than actually
flying the helicopter
around it's interesting
that's what eventually
evolved into SimCity
that's interesting you
had more fun designing
the world yeah part of
it and then being like wouldn't everybody else
would like to do this
this needs a financial
district I kind of get
that though because there
are a lot of like games
or just stories in general
that I like the lore or
like the background world
building more than I like
any of the stories so I
could see that coming from
the creator as well yeah
and then on publishing a
lot of people had spent
years learning the Apple
2 but the Commodore 64
seemed more of a level
playing field because
everyone was starting from
scratch on that so I
bought my early Commodore
64 right when it came out
and dove into it and
learned every bit of it I
did my first game Raid on
Bungeling Bay on that right
around the time I moved to
California there was
about I don't know maybe
three game publishers near
San Francisco Broderbund was
one of them I just drove to
each one and showed them
this game that I was
working on I really liked
the people at Broderbund so
I ended up working with
them what an interesting
time to just be like I'm
just gonna drive like I
don't have any connections
there but I'm just gonna knock on the door and be
like I made a game do you
want to see it wild west
time yeah and that's truly
like every that's what I get
from every developer too is
just like no matter who we
talk to whether it's Japan
or America or Rares
interviews it's always just
kind of like no one was
doing this but we were
doing it so we talked to
people who were also doing
it you know it's just weird
to think that it was that
easy to get into and now
it's something that people
will try yeah like well it's
so hard to do anything to
get involved yeah you know
it's a small market yeah yeah
and back there back then I
mean like you think about the
game industry now and just
how much like think about
just how much like one
company like Rockstar is
taking from from the pile
you know and then think
about like Nintendo Sony
and Microsoft too it's like
it's such a huge industry
it can't be understated I
think like you know you
think of it as just a
$60 game purchase when you
buy a new game but you
remember millions of other
people are buying that
$60 game like those profit
margins are huge compared
to game you know like
movies that sell at $17 a
ticket cash cow $17 a
ticket in New York I should
say some people will be
like oh my gosh that's
unreasonable stay where you
are you're lucky if your
tickets only 10 you might
complain about that but we
have to deal with 17 welcome to New York kid
and with that we will go
right into the essential
games list
and that's a great segue into
the essential games list
guys we're talking about
raid on bungeling bay you
know keep in mind that this
guy made Sim City the Sims
sport don't hold that
against him you mind that
he made those games you
know I'm not saying that
that doesn't mean that you
can like give this one a
pass or not but I really
don't think we should hold it any more favorable
because William Wright worked
on it just like we wouldn't
give Miyamoto a pass on
Donkey Kong so with that in
mind Sean Mike I first of
all I don't appreciate you
trying to color my response
okay I'm not I'm not a
more I don't know what that
that doesn't mean yeah it's a
more a I'm not I was never
gonna put this on the essential games list I am sort
of in love with this game but
I know that just by the way
that I voted in the past and
by what we're trying to do with
it it's not an essential game
it's got a lot of cool features
it's got a lot of interesting
systems I think it's probably
the most immersive game I've
played on the NES so far I love
just like what like just looking
at this and seeing what all of
the ideas turned into in the
future and I'm definitely
recommending it to anybody that's
into any kind of like whether
it's planes trains and
automobiles or or you're you just
like Sim City and you want to see
what it where it came from or you
just want to shoot down some
shoot down some fighter planes just
check it out but it's not
essential all right I'm gonna go
next since we're spinning up the
order here and I'm gonna say that
this is maybe the first NES game
that has surprised me I didn't even
think that something like this could
be done on the NES just to put it in
perspective Sim City was supposed to
come to the NES very late in the
life cycle and they have since found
like a beta version of it but of
course it wound up going into like
the early Super Nintendo launch but
these kinds of games are not really
like present on this system and so
just to see something like this in in
its wide scope performing pretty well
keep in mind like I mean we had like a
few things that like are definitely
like knocking it down but I think as
well as it performed this would have
been one of my favorite games around
that time you know like in 1987 I
would have been all over this thing
definitely but we have like evolved in
gaming in general like from that and I
definitely think that like this is
something that hasn't been copied that
much like like we've seen the real-time
aspect play out in games and we've
seen the like aerial dogfight thing
play out better in games but the two
of them together not something you see
every day I'm definitely not gonna put
this on the essential games list like
just because you know you don't get on
the essential games just because you
did something no one else has done but
I definitely think like if you haven't
if you're a guy who's been playing the
NES for like a few decades or you're
brand new to the NES I think that if
you haven't heard of this game before
and you know what William Wright has
done and you like that kind of thing
this is gonna be right up your alley
just like it was up mine and Sean's
like I definitely give this a huge
play it even if it's like for me
incredibly difficult I definitely give
it a huge play it just because it's
something that you're not gonna see
again I'm sure it had it has been
done please point it out yeah because
I want to play it right exactly I I just
think like those two elements being
combined is like a rare fusion that we
that we don't see too often so I'm
definitely not only has it piqued my
curiosity it's a strong game just not
strong enough by today's standards to
get it on the essential games list Joe
we didn't we didn't really say our
initial impressions I think that's
important to know what my initial
impression just from turning it on the
first screen my initial impression was
like oh god like it looked it gave me
very 1942 feels just by looking at it so
I was also pleasantly surprised actually
very similar to the way I was surprised
in last week's episode load runner
not surprised enough to remember the
name but but yeah I think that based on a
lot of the other things that we've seen
on the on this this is on this system
we've definitely this is definitely
doing a lot more it was more fun than I
thought it was going to be even before
you found out that the world is like
kind of reacting to what you're doing
which is just an incredibly impressive
biggest negative for me is the music but
that's not the reason that I'm going to
say it's not essential I think overall
it's not something that I'm actively
going to seek out to play again I I've
enjoyed playing it I'd also say it's a
play it but not essential Sam I I'm kind
of in the same boat as everyone else I
thought that this was possibly the most
unique game that we've played on this
system I and I haven't really played
anything like it on other systems I think
that if it had some kind of progression
system built into it you know where you
can upgrade your helicopter or you know
things change a little bit more than it
would be essential if there were if there
was more to it it would be but there
there is a lot going on there's like
different systems taking place and I
think it's definitely a play it but it's
not essential I think it has an amazing
foundation though and it could be it has
potential but it's not you definitely
have me now hankering for a sequel where
there are power-ups like I think yeah I
the ability to upgrade the helicopter and
it's funny because we always think about
like what what could this game have done
we didn't touch that in here but I do
think like you hit the nail on the head
there like that is definitely something
like yeah would definitely like sell me
on a sequel like I'm saying doesn't even
be in the original version but it should
be there the closest game that I can
think of did that sort of like emulates
parts of this game is sort of nothing
like it if you play Luftrausers anybody
no okay so Luftrausers is an indie game
it's you play as a single fighter jet that
you can customize with different kinds of
propulsion and firing types and bodies
types and you just sort of scroll around
this this area where you can where you
just do dog fights but it's a lot more
like trance inducing it's it's a lot more
fighting there aren't it's not as like
much of a simulation at all but I think
just like the movement style and sort of
just like the chaos that can unfold in
front of you in air combat is like the
closest I can I can get to what I've
played in in Raid on Bungeling Bay I think
that if this game and Gradius had a bit
a get a baby game together I was thinking
Gradius 2 when you mentioned up you know
some reason I think if there were like
like somehow like a boss fight where you
know you fight someone else in a helicopter
and you got like weave around each other or
something and you know upgrade systems so
you can change your weapons I think that
would be an amazing game I also think that
if we at some point play this multiplayer
if that is you know as well designed and is
and is as fun as I as I feel like it could
be I think that could I wouldn't know I
won't say that it would make me change
my vote but it would definitely take it
closer for me yeah we'll have to do that
before the end of 87 show right all right
that is all the time we have for this
episode of nostalgia a very surprising one
I think Raid on Bungeling Bay is one of
those games that I had never heard of
before this episode so even as it was
coming up I didn't like look at it and
be like hmm wonder what that's about also
should mention that the cover for this
game the front box are is like terrifying
yeah yeah it's like a big skull on it
like yeah exactly yeah I don't know if
we're gonna get any survival horror games
on the NES I think there is one that's
been mentioned to me but it was Japan only
so we'll have to yeah we'll have to go
do that anyway we will do that one time
soon hopefully go to Japan hopefully one
day I'd love to and yeah maybe nostalgia
goes to Japan the most expensive free
podcast episode ever okay I'm Michael
Sposito I make the website
nostalgia cast calm go there for show
notes and stuff I also curate the Twitter
feed so go to nostalgic at nostalgia cast
on Twitter and you'll see a bunch of
things about Raid on Bungeling Bay you
would have seen them this week but you
can check out next week's game bunch of
promotional art for that so that's cool
which is ring king so ring king get in
the ring king if you think you're the
ring king challenge us to a fight IRL find
me on the streets of Manhattan put up your
fists and I'll know what you're I'll
know what you're communicating I think
it's really cool that you're a listener
of this show before I kick your butt now
he's gonna kick my butt all right I'm
Michael Sposito you can find me on at
Sposito film on Twitter don't fight me
there only in real life please thank
you have a great day or morning
whatever or go to bed yeah whatever
time it is get eight hours of sleep
please you